in this complex numbers question we're
going to use some algebra and also some
of the foundational results
we've proved about how complex numbers
interact with each other
uh to provide an argument for some of
the things that you can sort of see
through
visual internet intuition and through
geometry but we're going to try and
prove it in a rigorous way
so let's get tucked into this you can
see we've got 17 and 18 together because
they kind of form one
coherent whole 17 says show that for any
non-zero complex number
zed and they've written it in polar form
that part a
z times its conjugate equals uh the
modulus of z
or squared so there are by the way i'm a
part b and a part c
to this question but i'm only going to
focus on part a because
that's the part that gets referred to in
the next question
so let's have a go at this the first
thing that i'm just going to flag which
seems a little bit unusual
is that this question says show that for
any non-zero
complex number um so they're actually
saying
any complex number except for the origin
that's the only one we're excluding
we'll come back to that point a little
bit
later on let's tuck into this result
that we're required to
prove z times its conjugate equals
the modulus of z all squared now what
they're doing is they're saying to us
from the outset
to find this in polar form and then see
what you can get from this right so i'm
going to say
if z is equal to
some modulus r times cos some
angle theta plus i sine something or
theta
then by definition the conjugate of z is
to take the imaginary part and
flip it upside down you know if you were
positive make it negative if you were
negative make it positive
so i would say in this form
the modulus is unchanged r stays the
same
cos theta also stays the same because
that's the real part
but here comes the imaginary part it's
minus
i sine theta because i'm taking the
opposite side
so now what happens when i multiply
these two things together well i would
say
z times its conjugate z bar
equals all right well let's let's see
what happens i'm going to be a little
bit lazy and just multiply these
like so so i think i'll just pop that
over there
what happens here well when we start to
simplify this out for starters you can
see
that you've got r and r just hanging out
the front there so i'll just write them
as
r squared and then what you've got if
you look closely here
is you've got something plus something
and something
minus something this is kind of a
difference of squares
situation here right a plus b a minus b
so i can just
factorize that as a squared minus b
squared so what do we get from that
cos squared theta that's my a squared
then
minus b squared but in this case we just
have to be a little bit careful because
the b
includes the i and the sine theta so
therefore
b squared will be i squared sine squared
theta okay so there's my a squared minus
b
squared but i know by definition that i
squared is equal to negative 1 so i'm
getting cos
squared theta plus sine squared theta
and by my handy dandy pythagorean
identity i can say that that part
is just equal to 1. so there's r squared
but thinking back to what i was supposed
to prove
r is the conjugate sorry is the modulus
rather
of z's so this is just the right hand
side that i was after
right so i can just substitute that as
the modulus z
squared as required okay so that was not
too arduous that was 17 part a and then
18 says
let z it starts off in a very similar
way let z be any non-zero complex number
and now as we read the next part of the
question we can see why they specify
that this had to be non-zero
it says by considering arg
of the absolute value of z or the
modulus of z squared
use this result that we just proved um
to show
that uh to prove that arg of the
conjugate is head equals
minus augzit okay so take a breath for a
second what's going on
why were they saying that we had to have
not just any complex number but a
non-zero complex number well it has to
do with the fact that they are
asking us to prove a result using
something to do with arguments right
now arguments we remember are the angle
starting from the positive real axis
that we rotate upwards anti-clockwise
until we are facing in the direction of
our said complex number
now every complex number on the complex
plane has
a well-defined argument except for one
point which is the origin because if you
want to think about it this way if i
just
draw a little complex plane here and if
i say oh
here is uh here's the origin what is the
angle at which you're facing to be
pointed at that
it doesn't make sense to pick any
particular angle over any other
you're always facing at the origin if
you're standing on it right so therefore
we say
arg 0 is undefined so that's why what
they're doing is they're trying to say
well look let's just let's just take
zero out of the running let's just not
consider that
as part of it and then let's think about
the arguments of the rest of these
so this is question 18.
when i want to think about arg of the
modulus of z
squared i can say since
[Applause]
you know the modulus is z squared if
i'm taking out the origin right then
this is just going to be if you want to
think about it this way um
going back into rectangular form it'll
we'll work it out as the square root of
a squared plus b squared
a and b both being real numbers so what
you're going to get here is going to be
a positive number right it's going to be
a positive number
on the real number line there's no
imaginary pieces
to our calculation of the modulus and so
i can say
especially because we've taken out zero
since the modulus of z squared
uh i should say modulus of z all squared
it has to be
a real positive number right um
because uh i'm excluding i'm excluding
zero
right maybe i should write that
as z is not equal to 0
i can say therefore that the argument of
the modulus of z squared is going to be
think about this right it's going to be
somewhere on the real number axis and on
the right hand side
but if we said that the argument is by
definition the angle
that you're facing at starting from the
real positive axis and retaining up
if you've got any number over here on
the real
axis on the positive side the argument
to all of these numbers is going to be
zero you don't have to rotate anywhere
this is your starting point right
so therefore i can say that argument is
going to be
zero but from part a i can substitute
this
for z times its conjugate right
so i can say that not just the argument
of the modulus we said
squared but the mod the argument of z
times its conjugate since those
are the same equals 0 2 from part a
so what i'm doing is
just like i noticed that these two
things
are equal i can say that these two
things are equal that's me using part a
so now that i've gotten to this where do
i go well as with all proof
questions what i'm going to try and do
is keep in mind my destination
in order to work out how i should
simplify the current thing that i'm
working on right
now you can see here's the destination i
need the argument of the conjugate of z
separate to the argument of z and at the
moment they're kind of tangled up
together
now at this point what i have to do is
use a result that i
proved when introducing the polar form
one of the main reasons
why we introduced polar form is because
it helps us understand what happens to
the arguments when you multiply two
complex numbers together so to remind
you let's have a look at our proof of
multiplication
in polar form we had to sort of do some
little work with trig identities here
to say when you take two arbitrary
complex numbers like
r1 r2 times cos alpha plus i sine alpha
cos beta plus i sine beta
what happens when you just expand that
all out and then when you collect the
the real and the imaginary parts then
you use the appropriate trig
identities we noticed that the moduli
get multiplied that's not relevant to us
at the moment the arguments are what
we're really interested in
and using these are trig expansions here
we notice that you add the arguments
together
if what you're doing is multiplying two
complex numbers
so therefore i can kind of do this in
reverse you can see i've got this
multiplication here and so the argument
of the the product here is going to be
the the sum of the two arguments that i
started with that is
arg of z plus
arg of z bar if you like just going back
to our proof
that's like this is the first number and
this z bar will be my second number
right so that's why you can see i'm
going to add these arguments together
which is what i'm doing here to get the
argument of the product right
so i haven't done anything to the right
hand side it's still 0.
but we're pretty much there aren't we
can you see what i'm trying to do
i want to prove that arg of the
conjugate of z equals minus r z but i'm
only one line away from that
all i have to do is subtract this arg
z from both sides so i'm going to do
that
arg of the conjugate of z equals minus
arg of z as required
so that's the whole proof and i'm just
to show you just to bring it full circle
right
what what this actually means if we are
to draw actually i'll do it this way
if we draw ourselves a little complex
plane here a bit messy we get the idea
if i had some arbitrary complex number
zed so long as it's not on the origin
and then i think about where is its
conjugate going to be well
the real part is going to be the same so
i'll still be on this same
vertical sorry same horizontal
coordinate but i go from this vertical
part here and i flip to the opposite
side so
my z bar will be somewhere around here
so then when i think about well what
direction am i facing in to be going up
to that
complex number versus going to this
complex number
you can see well if this is theta then
this
angle down here will be the same size
but in the opposite
direction which is to say the argument
of the conjugate which is
this angle down here it's the same as
going to the original number but
minus so instead of going up that way
i'm going to go down that way
and you could probably look at this and
say oh well it must be true because
visually it is the case
and what we've done is we've used our
our knowledge of complex numbers how
they're
defined and what happens when we put all
this arithmetic together
to get our result here so it doesn't
just look like it's true
it absolutely can be proven